[Musique]
ça laisse l'original c'est le récit ma
copine mais une amie qui n'a pas juste
il est meilleur quand je ne pourrais pas
avoir une relation durant parce que pour
toi une femme est intéressante que si tu
savais quand tu as vu ce que tu es job
plus avérée non mais bon je peux très
bien changer l'image dentaire j'ai dit
que je veux je veux parler paru trois
ans et devrait glisser comme une lettre
à la poste qui doit se débrouiller pour
les à croire que tu cherches une
relation durable et monogame d'ici et un
sac rouge bastia non pas du tout quelque
chose me dit qu'il a une demande
particulière en faire écoute choix
seraient combattues addict aux mecs qui
sont ignorés lydia as tu tombe bien il
faut qu on a saboté ma voiture un abc
n'a ni la mousse polyuréthanne dans mon
tuyau d'échappement
tu n'aurais pas une petite fille et que
l'enfant existe un besoin d'eux
[Musique]
donc qui à vivre comme un homme exquis
arrivera jamais si tu arrives à bouger
ton p'tit gars fier de cette mode et
tendance ça veut dire que tu peux avoir
des plans fixes qu'on nous dit lui-même
le plus grand show la fin de toute la
ville qui est amour il a donc pas de
chance elle tombe amoureuse de lycéens
maintenant je ne veux pas vous aimez il
s'est collé contre moi et un moment j'ai
senti que ça lui plaisait comment est-ce
que tu la sainte
le prince avec une sortie wii et une 106
magie
[Musique]
le prix n'a marre j'ai besoin que tu
m'aimes tu meurs
[Musique]
des couvertures vertes
il
au moins j'aurai su quoi faire je
devrais retourner éclater la tête comme
ça contre le réfrigérateur
c'est très sain